I'm not much of a teacher now you tell
me but I do have a great idea for
Science Club
tomorrow you going to go back in time
and keep yourself from delivering that
lecture I know you still don't believe
me but isn't the foundation of science
to have an open
mind science is about proof you want
proof if I remember right this week a
freak snowfall closed to Main Road
between here and
Willoughby uh this week's forecast is
nothing but clear sunny
skies we'll
see this one's pretty
nice that's a way better tree over there
you're doing it again huh every single
time I do something you always have to
try to outdo me no that's all in your
head the academic de cathlon the 4H
competition oh I could go on you you
remember all of that that's just proof
that you've been jealous of me ever
since back in high school what you've
always been jealous of me
please I love my
life do
you ok fine I admit it my life is far
from
perfect this week I have a second chance
and I'm going to make a
difference starting with getting Miss
Nelson that tree oh watch
out I'd say the weather has changed well
that's hardly
proof time will
[Music]
tell